ça saigne et jean françois tardif et
c'est pour la première fois le prototype
de vêtements qu'il veut tester en mai
2016 au sommet de l'everest
j'ai souvent regardé parce que tu es
dans la peau chinoise
c'est le tout premier vêtement de sport
extrême matelassé en asclépiades ou soit
d'amérique cette fibre naturelle récolté
au québec c'est chaud
nous allons présenter si la différence
de comportement des plumes et duvets par
rapport à lass les piannencs françois
simard qui a redécouvert les propriétés
de l'asclépiade a fait tous les tests
pour prouver qu'elle surpasse le duvet
et les fibres synthétiques allées
chaudes et imperméables
l'asclépiade euro poussent l'eau et ne
se déforme pas
la plus lourde uv s'affaisse au contact
de l'eau ce qui réduit d'autant dans
l'existence au transfert thermique
le polyester aussi est imperméable mais
est-il aussi chaud que la soie
d'amérique on cherche à déterminer si
l'un à une meilleure résistance aux
transferts de charges à poids et volume
égal la neige contenu dans le vert font
plus vite à droite au dessus du
synthétique que sur la sq les piannencs
voici le test en accéléré l'expérience
duré quatorze minutes le polyester
comparativement à la slep yade en moins
de capacités isolantes
reste à tester dans la vraie vie le
prototype de vêtements donc ça c'est le
premier de tout premier manteau en acier
piazza
26 9
il touche au sénat quelques courtes
il
début mars jean françois tardif
alpinistes amateurs de haut niveau et
marc tremblay pdg de chlorophylle la
firme québécoise qui est dessiné le
prototype font l'ascension du mont
lafayette dans le new hampshire à 1600
mètres d'altitude
on devrait avoir moins 30 ou chat mais
on a des enfants d'à peu près 25 km
aricie denquin rossard souffler
les sommets des montagnes blanches comme
le mont lafayette ont la réputation
d'avoir un des pires climat de la
planète des vents changeants glaciaux au
dessus de la ligne des arbres
marc et jean françois ont trouvé les
conditions difficiles dans beaucoup de
neige six heures plus tard ils sont
revenus à la base pour l'instant aux 20
minutes mois et qu'elle montre ' la
performance de l'isolant c'est chaud du
poids de problème le prêtre est
traîtresse comme premier test
au café du coin les deux randonneurs
confirme que l'endroit était le bon pour
les essais en grade ce froide très
froide en eau
certainement moins 30 et plus
on a eu un wipeout donc on voyait plus
rien les deux caméras que nous leur
avions fournies n'ont rien vu non plus
au sommet elle était gelée elles n'ont
pas fonctionné il y avait deux choses à
tester le produit en interne le fit la
technicité du produit comme ça bouge
commença travail et aussi la chaleur la
charge pense que dans ses conclusions
moi je pense qu'il va vouloir en arriver
mais ça c'est clara fils qui va vers des
cieux avec françois ce marché protection
lafayette a bien été un peu chaud
retrouvez sans cacher qu'il y avait deux
couches jetables comme tu peux voir
c'est ce qui est à l'intérieur
peut-être que si on en était seulement
une ce soit suffisant et le chou de
voiteur compresseur plus léger ouais
c'est ça ça me rendait beaucoup de poils
le rembourrage et fabriqués par cette
machine qui étale couche après couche un
voile de fibres d'ascq les pyatt
stabiliser c'est l'épaisseur de ce
rembourrage qu'il faudra doser et tester
à nouveau on avait un comparatif
standards du marché a enduré et puis on
a essayé de se rapprocher le plus
possible on a des ajustements faire bien
évidemment mais on est assez ravi des
conclusions qui nous rapprochent du
moment fatidique où l'everest sera monté
jean-michel un script elle a donc dû
qualités d'isolant thermique mais y en a
d'autres oui tout à fait cette fibre
naturelle est un excellent absorbant de
produits pétroliers en cas de
déversement accidentel dans un reportage
précédent on a parlé de ce contrat de
parcs canada justement pour équiper tous
les parcs nationaux de trousse d'urgence
à base d'ascq les piannencs est donc
pour l'instant lusine de granby on voit
ces containers qui vont partir et toute
la récolte de 2014 donc la première fois
qu'on a récolté de l'asclépiade qui a
été semé on appelle ça le souhait du
québec est épuisé mais la demande risque
d'être exponentielle on voit notre
climat comment est-ce qu'ils vont être
capables de fournir alors c'est le défi
évidemment mesurer la demande l'offre
beaucoup d'agriculteurs sont intéressés
on a récolté 20 hectares cette année on
parle de 200 hectares l'an prochain
c'est énorme et on accuse annoncé la
création d'une première usine de
transformation en dehors de l'usiné
expérimentale de granby à saint tite en
mauricie là où ses formes est la
première coopérative d'agriculteurs qui
a pris le nom des papillons fameux
papillon monarque très bien alors vous
continuez de suivre cette fascinante
histoire pour nous merci rien